there are plenty of people in Donald
Trump's Whitehouse who think climate
change isn't a big deal or who think
that climate change is somewhat of a
hoax altogether like for example the
President himself Donald Trump but it's
I hesitate to use this word but to some
degree refreshing to know that defense
secretary James Madison's not one of
them and it's refreshing to know that
every once in a while someone in Trump's
White House says something that makes
some semblance of sense before we get
back to James Madison you for context
that Scott Pruett the new administrator
of the Environmental Protection Agency
blew people's minds when he said that
climate change is not caused by carbon
dioxide but written statements from
cabinet hearings were recently leaked
and it was discovered that mattis
actually wrote some pretty sensible
things for example quote climate change
is impacting stability in areas of the
world where our troops are operating
today it is appropriate for the
combatant commands to incorporate
drivers of instability that impact the
security environment in their areas into
their planning he's saying climate
change is a national defense and
national security issue that's something
many progressives have been saying for a
long time nobody's questioning the
authenticity of these leaks okay it's
been confirmed by Senate staff there's
really no question about whether mattis
really said this there's obviously many
other reasons to be afraid of climate
change but National Defense is probably
an overlooked one and it makes sense
that maddest will be concerned about
that and it's also Pat a good idea to
appeal to the right on this issue it's
crazy that saying to someone on the
right we're destroying our planet may
not be a good way to appeal to them on
this issue but if we have to talk about
national defense and national security I
think it's great to talk to
right-wingers about this another quote
from Mad ascent
climate change can be a driver of
instability and the Department of
Defense must pay attention to potential
adverse impacts generated by this
phenomenon and also another quote from
James Madison firmed I will ensure that
the Department of Defense plays its
appropriate role within such a response
by addressing national
security aspects I agree that the
effects of a changing climate such as
increased maritime access to the Arctic
rising sea levels desertification among
others impact our security situation
what a lot of people don't get that the
military knows a lot about earth science
and climate change because they have to
and it's funny when only the be one of
the only cabinet members who is remotely
qualified for their job is the only guy
saying that climate change is a problem
that's not even a position that the
Trump administration has conceded so far
I mean remember when everyone laughed at
Bernie Sanders for saying that the
biggest risk to our national security is
climate change yeah now you have someone
in the Trump administration who kind of
agrees to that viewpoint to some extent
yeah I actually kind of like mattis I
mean he seemed to have convinced Trump
at least for a time that waterboarding
was a bad method to get information out
of people yep and we should take on the
carrot approach rather than the stick
approach no down so if I was a senator I
probably would have voted for him I can
find many things about James Madison
disagree with but we've at least found
two instances the torture one that Pat
mentioned and these recent comments that
have leaked about climate change that
make him one of the more logical people
on Trump's staff conservatives love and
trust the military he should try to
drive his point home to trump and the
EPA maybe the military would be the only
way to get through to Trump about this
issue and this is one of those areas
where the Trump nationalism the
nationalism we're seeing rise in Europe
to some degree it does not work in the
context of climate change it's a
particularly bad time for this type of
nationalism because climate change
pollution our oceans becoming cesspools
of trash these issues don't respect
country lines and therefore I'm not
talking about NWO globalist government
conspiracy theories I'm saying an
isolationist nationalist approach cannot
solve these issues because the issues
don't respect country borders and I wish
the Nationalists would get that and not
only do they not respect country borders
they also can't be put on hold for for
you
until a different President is elected
into office and we need to act now and
it doesn't seem like that's gonna happen
we needed to act 10 years ago and of
course now is the next-best date to
start acting and we're not seeing that
happen send me your thoughts about this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show
we've got a great program for you today